you
here are two K of the past couple weeks
we have been getting some terrifying
face scans and the spirit of Halloween
we wanted to provide you guys some
simple instructions to make your own
terrifying face scan the first step to
getting inaccurate skin tones is to turn
off the lights step 2 hold the camera at
a reasonable distance from your face and
make sure not to hold still step 3
quickly turn your head left and right to
ensure that the camera does not get an
accurate scan of your face step 4 make
sure you continuously blink your eyes
the faster you can bleak your eyes the
better and finally step 5 never
maintained the same facial expression
during the scanning process just follow
these simple instructions and you'll be
well on your way to creating your own
terrifying face scan let's take a look
at some examples so there you have it
join us this friday on Halloween in my
Park and bring your most terrifying face
can we look forward to seeing you there
happy Halloween
you